the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
today we are going to see how to use
what we saw last time about partial
derivatives
to handle minimization or maximization
problems involving consents of several
variables so if all that so remember
last time we say that when we have a
function say of two variables x and y
then we have actually two different
derivatives partial F partial X also
called F sub X is the derivative with
respect to X keeping Y constant
and we have partial f / 4y also called F
sub y where we vary Y and we paid X as a
constant
okay and now one thing I didn't have
time to tell you about but hopefully you
thought about in recitation yesterday is
the approximation formula that tells you
what happens if you vary both x and y so
f sub x tells us what happens if we
change X a little bit by some small
amount Delta X F sub y tells us how f
changes if we change Y by a small amount
Delta Y if we devolve at the same time
then the two effects will add up with
each other right because you can imagine
that first you will change X and then
you will change Y or the other way
around it doesn't really matter so if we
change X by a certain amount Delta X and
if we change Y by the amount Delta Y and
let's say that we have Z equals f of X Y
then that changes by an amount which is
approximately f sub x times Delta X plus
F sub y times Delta Y and that's one of
the most important formulas about
partial derivatives okay so the
intuition for this again is just the two
effects add up if I change X by a small
amount and then I change Y well plus
changing X will modify F how much does
it modify F the answer is the rate of
change is ad sub X and if I change Y
then the rate of change of F when I
change Y is f sub y so altogether I get
this change in the value of F and of
course that's only an approximation
formula actually there would be higher
order terms involving second and third
derivatives and so on
so one way to justify this
so I was distracted by microphone
problem okay
so how do we justify this formula well
one way to think about it is in terms of
tangent plane approximation so let's
think about the tangent plane to the
graph of a function f this we have some
pictures to show you will be easier if I
show the pictures okay so remember
partial F partial X was obtained by
looking at the situation where Y is held
constant so that means I'm slicing the
graph of F by a plane that's parallel to
the XZ plane and then when I change X Z
changes and the slope of that is going
to be the derivative with respect to X
so now if I do the same in the other
direction then I will have similarly the
slope in a slice now parallel to the Y Z
plane that will be partial F partial Y
so in fact in each case I have a line
and that line is tangent to the surface
so now if I have two lines tangent to
the surface
well then together the determine for me
the tangent plane to the surface okay so
let's try to see how that works so
we know that f sub X and F sub y our
slopes are the slopes of two tangent
lines to this plane sorry
mm lines to the graph and let's write
down the equations of these lines I'm
not going to write parametric equations
I'm going to write them in terms of XYZ
coordinates so let's say that partial F
over partial X at the given point is
equal to a then that means that we have
a line given by the following conditions
so I'm going to keep Y constant equal to
y0 and I'm going to change X and as I
change X Z will change at a rate that's
equal to a so that would be Z equals Z 0
plus a times the change in X X minus x0
ok that is how you would describe a line
that I guess the one that's plotted in
green here that's intersection with a
slice parallel to the XZ plane I hold Y
constant equal to y 0 and Z is a
function of X that varies with a weight
of a and now if I look similarly the
other slice let's say that the partial
with respect to Y is equal to B then I
get another line which is obtained by
the fact that Z now will depend on Y and
the rate of change with respect to Y
will be B while X is held constant equal
to X 0 so these two lines are both going
to be in the tangent plane to the
surface
so they're both tension ^ f and well
together take a time in a plane that
name is just given by the formula Z
equals Z 0 plus a times X minus x0 plus
B times y minus y 0 all right if you
look at what happens so this is the
equation of a plane Z equals constant
times X plus constant times y plus
constant and if you look at what happens
if I hold Y constant and vary X I
recover the first line if I hold X
constant and vary Y I get the second ok
another way to do it of course would be
to write actually parametric equations
of these lines get vectors along them
and then take the cross-product to get
the normal vector to the plane and then
get this equation for the plane using
the normal vector that also works Li
gives you the same formula so if you're
curious exercise do it again using
parametric's and using cross-product to
get the plane equation ok so that's how
we get the tangent plane and now what
this approximation formula here says is
that in fact the graph of a function is
close to the tangent plane okay if we
are moving on the tangent plane this
would be an actual equality Delta Z
would be a linear function of Delta X
and Delta Y and the graph of a function
is near the tangent plane but it's not
quite the same so it's only an
approximation for small Delta X and
small Delta Y
so the approximation formula says the
graph of F is closed with Stanton okay
and we can use that formula over here
now to estimate how the value of F
changes if I change x and y at the same
time okay questions about that
okay so now that we've caught up with
what we were supposed to see on Tuesday
I can tell you now about Max and main
problems
so that's going to be an application of
partial derivatives to look at
optimization problems okay so maybe you
know ten years from now when you have a
real job your job might be to actually
minimize the cost of something or
maximize the profit of something
whatever but typically the function that
you will have to you know strive to
minimize or maximize will depend on
several variables so if you have a
function of one variable you know that
to find its minimum know its maximum you
look at the derivative and you set that
equal to zero and you try to then look
at what happens to the function so here
it's going to be kind of similar except
of course we have several derivatives
okay so for today we'll think about a
function of two variables but it works
exactly the same if you have three
variables ten variables a million
variables so the first observation is
that so if we have a local minimum or a
local maximum then both partial
derivative the so partial F partial X
and partial F partial Y are both 0 at
the same time so why is that well let's
say that F sub X is 0 that means when I
vary X well to first order of the
function doesn't change
maybe that's because it's going through
if I look only at the slice parallel to
the x-axis then maybe I'm going for the
minimum but then if partial F partial Y
is not 0 then actually by changing Y I
could still make a value larger or
smaller so that wouldn't be an actual
maximum or minimum it would only be a
maximum or minimum if I stay in the
slice but if I allow myself to change Y
that doesn't work so I need actually to
know that if I change Y value will not
change either to first order so that's
why I also need partial F partial Y to
be 0 now let's say that we are both 0
well why is that enough it's essentially
enough because of this formula telling
me that if both of these guys are 0 then
to first order of the function doesn't
change and then of course there will be
maybe quadratic terms that will actually
turn that you know this won't really say
that your function is actually constant
will just tell you that maybe it will be
actually quadratic or higher order in
Delta X and Delta Y that's what you
expect to have at the maximum or minimum
okay so we have
so that condition is the same thing as
saying that the tangent plane to the
graph is actually going to be horizontal
okay and that's what you want to have
say you have a minimum well see that the
tangent plane at this point at the
bottom of the graph is going to be
horizontal and you can see that on this
equation of a tangent plane when both
these coefficients are 0 that's when the
equation becomes Z equals constant the
horizontal plane it does that make sense
ok so we'll have a name for this kind of
point because actually what we'll see
very soon is that these conditions are
necessary but they are not sufficient
there's actually other kinds of points
where the partial derivatives are zero
so let's give a name to this we say
definition we say that X let's say X 0 y
0 is a critical point of F if the
partial derivative with respect to X and
the partial derivative respect to Y are
both 0
marginally you would want all the
partial derivatives no matter how many
variables you have you want all the
partials to be 0 at the same time
so let's see an example
so let's say I give you the function f
of XY equals x squared minus 2xy plus
say Y squared plus 2x minus 2y okay
and let's try to figure out whether we
can minimize or maximize this well so
what we'd start doing immediately is
taking the partial derivatives okay so
what is f sub X it starts with 2x minus
2y plus 0 plus 2 remember that y is a
constant so this differentiates to 0 now
if we do F sub y that's going to be well
0 minus 2x + 6 y -2 and what we want to
do is set these things equal to 0 and we
want to solve these two equations at the
same time ok so an important thing to
remember I mean maybe I should have told
you couple of weeks ago already if you
have two equations to solve well it's
very good to try to simplify them by
adding them together or whatever but you
must keep two equations okay if you have
two equations you should not end up with
just one equation out of nowhere okay so
for example here we can certainly
simplify things by summing them together
see if we add them together while the
X's cancel and the constants cancel and
back we're just left with 4y 4 0 that's
pretty good that tells us why it should
be 0 but then we should of course go
back to these and see what else we know
well now it tells us so if you put y
equals 0 it tells you to x plus 2 equals
0
that tells you x equals minus 1 okay so
we have one critical point that's X y
equals minus 1 and 0 okay any questions
so far well you should have a question
question should be how do we know if
it's the maximum or minimum
well yeah so if we had a function of one
variable we would decide things based on
the second derivative and in fact we'll
see tomorrow how to do things based on
the second derivative but let's kind of
tricky because there's a lot of second
derivatives I mean we already have two
first derivatives you can imagine that
if you keep taking partials you may end
up with you know more and more so we'll
have to figure out carefully what the
condition should be so we'll do that
tomorrow
for now let's just try to look a bit at
how do we understand these things by
hand so in fact let me point out to you
immediately that there's more than
maxima and minima so remember we saw you
know the example of x squared plus y
squared that has a critical point the
critical point is obviously a minimum
and of course it could be a local
minimum because it could be that you
know if you have a more complicated
function there is indeed a minimum here
but then elsewhere the function drops to
a lower value so we call that just we
call that just a local minimum to say
that it's a minimum if you stick to
values that are close enough to that
point of course you also have a local
maximum where I didn't plot it but it's
easy to plot okay
that's a local maximum but there's a
third example of critical point and
that's a saddle point okay so the saddle
point it's a new phenomenon that you
don't really see in the single variable
calculus it's a critical point that's
neither a minimum nor a maximum because
depending on which direction you look in
it's either one or the other so here see
the point in the middle at the origin is
a saddle point just you know if you look
at the tangent plane to this graph
you'll see that it's actually horizontal
at the origin you have this mountain
pass you know the mountain pass
to ground this horizontal but depending
on in which direction you go you go up
or down so we say that a point is a
saddle point if it's neither a minimum
nor a maximum
okay so possibilities could be a local
min a local max well I said okay so
tomorrow we'll see how to decide which
one it is in general using second
derivatives for this time let's just try
to do it in your by hand so I just want
to observe in fact I can try to you know
these examples that I have here they are
X square plus y square Y square minus X
square the sums or differences of
squares and if we know that we can put
thing as a sum of squares for example
we'll be done so let's try to express
phase maybe as the square of something
well so the problem the main problem is
this 2xy but observe we know something
that starts with x squared minus 2xy
that is actually the square of something
else right it would be X square minus
2xy well plus y squared not plus 3y
squared so let's try to do that so we
are going to complete the square
so I'm going to say it's X minus y
squared and then so that gives me the
first two terms and also Y squared when
I still need to add two more Y squares
and I also need to add across the 2x and
minus 2y
it's central it's still not simple
enough my taste I can actually do better
see I mean now what's so these guys look
like a sum of squares but here I have
this x5 stuff but Oh 2x minus 2y well
that's twice X minus y it looks like
maybe we can modify this and make this
into another square okay so in fact I
can simplify this further 2x minus y
plus 1 square see that would start like
that would be X minus y squared plus
twice X minus y and then there's a plus
1 well we don't have that plus 1 so
let's remove it by so triangle okay oh
let it fight that minus 1 here and I
still have my 2y squared ok do you see
why this is the same function as that
one yeah so again you know if I expand X
minus y plus 1 squared I get X minus y
squared plus twice X minus y that's
those guys
plus 1 but I will have minus 1 that will
cancel out and then I have a plus 2 y
squared
okay so now what I know see this is a
sum of two squares minus 1 and this
critical point XY equals minus 1 0
that's exactly when this is zero and
that is a zero so that's the smallest
value this is always greater or equal to
zero
same with that one so that's always at
least minus 1 and minus 1 happens to be
the value at the critical point so it's
a minimum okay now of course here I was
very lucky in general I couldn't expect
things to simplify that much in fact I
cheated I stopped it from that i
expanded and then that's how I got my
example okay so but general method will
be a bit different but you will see it
will actually also involve completing
squares just there's more to it than
what we've seen
ok so we'll come back to this tomorrow
sorry
oh do I how do I know that this equals y
is what negative 1
how do I know that that whole function
is greater or equal to negative one well
I vote f of XY as something squared plus
2y squared minus one okay this squared
it's always a positive number
non-negative right it's a square the
square of something is always
non-negative similarly Y squared is also
always non-negative so if you add
something that's at least zero plus
something that's at least zero and you
subtract one you get always at least
minus one and in fact the only way that
you can get minus one is if both of
these guys are zero at the same time
okay so that's how I get my minimum so
now about this tomorrow
so in fact what I would like to tell you
about now instead is a nice application
of min max problems that maybe you don't
think of as a min max problem that you
will see because I mean you don't think
that way
because probably your calculator can do
it for you or if not your computer can
do it for you but it's actually
something where the theory is based on
minimization in two variables so very
often in experimental sciences you have
to do something called least squares
interpolation and what is that about
well it's the idea that maybe you do
some experiments and you know you record
some data so you have some data X and
some other data Y and I don't know maybe
for example X is a MIDI measuring frogs
and you're trying to measure how big the
frog leg is compared to the eyes of the
frog or whether or you know trying to
measure something and you know if you're
doing chemistry then it could be you
know how much you put up some of
reactant and the output how much of the
output product that you wanted to
synthesize is generated all sorts of
things make up your own example but so
you know if you measure R basically for
various values of X what the value of y
ends up being and then you know you
would like to claim oh well these points
are kind of aligned and of course to a
mathematician they are not aligned but
to an experimental scientist that's
evidence that there's a relation between
the two and so you want to claim and you
know in your paper you will actually
draw a nice little line like that see
these two functions depend linearly on
each other ok so the question is how do
we come up with that nice line that
passes smack in the middle of the points
so the question is given
experimental data X I Y I so maybe I
should actually be more precise so
you're given some experimental data you
have data point x1 y1 x2 y2 and so on xn
yn the question would be find the best
fit line from y equals ax plus B that
somehow in you know approximates very
well this data so you know you can also
use that by the way to predict various
things for example if you look at your
new homework
actually the first problem asks you to
predict how many iPods will be on this
planet in 10 years okay looking at you
know best sales and how they behave one
thing by the way before you you know
lose all the money you don't have yet
you cannot use that to predict the stock
market okay so don't try to use that to
make money it doesn't work so
one tricky thing here that I want to
draw your attention to is what are the
unknowns here so the natural answer
would be to say well the unknowns are X
and y that's not a trivial case
okay we are not trying to solve for some
x and y I mean we have some values given
to us and when we are looped right well
when we are looking for that line we
don't really care about the particular
value of x what we care about is
actually these coefficients a and B that
will tell us what the relation is
between x and y so in fact we are trying
to solve for a and B that will give us
the nicest possible line for these
points okay so the unknowns in our
equations will have to be a and B not x
and y
okay so the question really is find the
best a and and of course we have to
decide what we mean by best so best will
mean that we minimize some function of a
and B that measures the total error that
we are making when we are choosing this
line compared to the experimental data
so maybe roughly speaking it should
measure how far these points are from
the line but now there's various ways to
do it and some of them are I mean
they're all actually you know a lot of
them are valid they give you different
answers you have to decide what it is
that you prefer so for example you could
measure off a distance to the line you
know by projecting perpendicularly or
you can measure instead the difference
between for a given value of x the
difference between the experimental
value of y and the predicted one and
that's often more relevant because you
know these guys are actually maybe
expressing different units they are not
the same type of quantity so you can
actually combine them arbitrarily but
anyway so the convention is usually we
measure distance in this way next we
could try to minimize the largest
distance you know say we look at well
the largest error and we make that the
smallest possible the drawback of doing
that is experimentally very often you
have one data point that's not good
because maybe you know you fell asleep
in front of the experiment and so you
don't measure the right thing so you
tend to want to you know not give too
much importance to some data point
that's far away from the others so maybe
instead you want to measure you know the
average distance maybe you want to
actually give more weight to things but
how further away and then you don't want
to do the distance with the square of a
distance so there's various possible
answers but one one of them gives us
actually a particularly nice formula for
a and B and so that's why it's the
universally used one
okay answer so here it says
least-squares so that's because we'll
measure actually the sum of the squares
of the arrows and why do we do that well
part of it is because actually it looks
good I mean when you see these plots in
scientific papers they really look like
the line is indeed the ideal line and
the second reason is because actually
the minimization problem that we will
get is particularly simple well-posed
and it's easy to solve so we'll have a
nice formula for the best a and the best
B so you know if you have a method
that's simple and gives you a good
answer then that's probably the good one
so okay so we have to define best and
here it's in the sense of minimizing the
total square so I mean it's a total
square deviation into that instead okay
so what do I mean by that so the
deviation for each data point is the
difference between what you have
measured and what you are predicting by
your model okay so that's the difference
between y i and ax i plus B okay
so now what we'll do is we'll try to
minimize the function capital T which is
just the sum for all the data points of
the square of the deviation okay so
let me emphasize again this is a
function of a and B and of course
there's a lot of letters in here but X I
and why I in a real life it would be
numbers given to you they will be the
numbers that you have measured you've
measured all of this data they are just
going to be numbers you put them in
there and you get a function of a and B
okay any questions
yes okay so how do we minimize this
function of a and B well let's use a new
knowledge let's actually look for a
critical point so we want to solve for
partial D over partial a equals zero and
partial D over partial V equals zero
that's how we look for critical points
so let's take the derivative of this
with respect to a well so it's going to
be when the derivative of a sum is sum
of the derivatives and now we have to
take the derivative of this quantity
squared so you remember how we take the
derivative of the square we take twice
this quantity times the derivative of y
plus square so we get two times minus y
I sorry why I minus ax plus B times the
derivative of this with respect to a
what's the derivative of this with
respect to a negative x I exactly okay
and so we'll want this to be zero and
partial you have a partial B we do the
same thing but differentiating with
respect to B instead of respect to a so
again sum of squares twice Y I minus ax
plus B times derivative of this with
respect to B is is I think negative one
okay so that's the equations we have to
solve
well let's reorganize this a little bit
so the first equation so see there's a s
and verse B's in these equations I'm
going to just look at the coefficients
of a and B if you have good eyes you can
see probably by design the linear
equations in a and B also there's a lot
of clutter with all these X's and Y's
all over the place okay so let's
actually try to expand things and make
that more abound
so first thing I will do is I will
actually get rid of these factors of two
that are just you know not very
important I can simplify things by two
and next I'm going to look at the
coefficient of a well I will get
basically a times X I squared well let
me just do it and
and it should be clear so I claim when
we simplify this we get X I squared
times a plus X I times B minus X I Y I
and we set this equal to 0 do you agree
that this is what we get when we expand
that product yeah kind of
ok let's do the other one so we just
multiply by -1 so we take the opposite
of that it will be ax I plus B I will
write that as X X I a plus B minus y I
and also I forgot the N and let me just
reorganize that by actually putting you
know all the A's together that means
actually I will have sum of all the X I
squared times a plus son of X I times B
minus sum of X I Y I equals 0
so I rewrite this it becomes sum of X I
squared times a plus sum of the X is
times B minus 1 let me move the other
guys to the other side equals sum of X I
Y and that one becomes sum of X I times
a plus how many bees do I get on this
one when I get one for each data point
when I sum them together I will get n
very good so n times B equals sum of Y
ok now these quantities will look scary
but they're actually just numbers right
for example for this one you look at all
your data points for each of the
military value of x and you just sum all
these numbers together so what you get
actually is a linear system in a and B a
two by two linear system
and so now we can solve this for a and B
so in practice of course first you plug
in the numbers for X I and Y I and then
you solve the system that you get okay
and we know how to solve 2x2 linear
systems I hope okay so that's how we
find the best fit line now why is that
going to be the best one instead of the
worst one you know we just sort of
thought critical point that could
actually be a maximum of this error
function indeed well so we'll have
actually the answer to that next time
but trust me if you really want to go
for the second derivative test that
we'll see two more and apply it in this
case it's quite hard to check but you
can see it's actually a minimum so I'll
just say
we can show that it's a minimum
okay now even if Overland in our case is
the one that we have a most familiar
with least-squares interpolation
actually works in much more general
settings because instead of fitting for
WebEx nine if you think that has a
different kind of relation then maybe
you can fit you know in using a
different kind of formula so let me
actually illustrate that with an example
so I don't know if you're familiar with
Moore's Law it's something that's
supposed to tell you how quickly
basically computer chips become smarter
faster and faster all the time it's a
law that says things about the number of
transistors that you can fit onto a
computer chip so here I have some data
about oh okay so okay
so here's data about the number of
transistors on you know standard PC
processor as a function of time and well
you know if you try to do the best line
fit well you'll see quickly that it
doesn't seem to follow a linear trend
okay on the other hand if you plug the
diagram in a log scale with so the log
of the number of transistors as a
function of time then you get a much
better line and so in fact that means
that you had an exponential relation
between the number of transistors and
time and so actually that's what most
law says it says that the number of
transistors on the chip doubles every so
depending on the version every 18 months
or every two years they keep changing
the statement but so how do we find that
best exponential fit well so an
exponential fit would be something of
the form y equals a constant times
exponential of a times X okay that's
what we want to look at when we could
try to minimize a square error like we
did before that doesn't work well at all
the equations that you get are very
complicated you can solve them but
remember what I showed you on this log
plot right if you plot the log of Y as a
function of X then suddenly it becomes a
linear relation so observe this is the
same as Ln of y equals Ln of C plus ax
and that is a linear best fit so what
you do
if you just look for the best straight
line fit for the log of Y so that's
something we already know but you can
also do other examples for example let's
say that you know we have something more
complicated let's say that we have
actually a quadratic law so for example
Y is of the form ax squared plus BX plus
C and of course you're trying to find
you know somehow the best so that would
mean here fitting the best parabola for
your data points well to do that you
will need to find a B and C and now you
would have actually a function of a B
and C which would be the sum over all
data points of the squared deviation and
if you try to solve for critical points
so now you will have three equations
involving a B and C and in fact you will
find a way by fill in your system and it
works just the same way just you have a
little bit more data so basically you
see that these best fit problems an
example of you know minimization problem
that maybe you didn't expect to see
minimization problems come in but that's
very the way to handle these questions
okay so tomorrow we'll go back to the
question of how do we decide whether
it's the minimum or maximum and we'll
continue exploring some sense of several
variables
you